this is a Fox News Alert the New York
Times is reporting that in 2017 the FBI
opened an investigation into whether
President Trump was secretly a Russian
agent trace Gallagher is following this
report for us tonight race yeah just
came out Tucker The Times is now
reporting that in the days President
Trump fired James Comey the days after
as FBI director law enforcement
officials became so concerned about the
president's behavior they began
investigating whether he'd been working
on behalf of Russia in other words
whether the president's actions
constituted a threat to national
security and whether Trump unwittingly
had falled under Moscow's influence now
the reasons given the first was a letter
mr. Trump water to send mr. Comey about
his firing but never did' in which he
mentioned the Russia investigation in
the letter and the second reason being
that troubled investigators was an NBC
News interview two days after commis
firing in wist which mr. Trump appeared
to say he had dismissed mr. Comey
because of the Russian inquiry the
investigation also reportedly looked
into the public allegations of whether
firing Comey
a matter - obstruction of justice we all
know that the report says FBI agents had
grown suspicious of Trump's ties to
Russia during that 2016 campaign but
held off opening an investigation
because of the sensitivity of the
situation of course days later special
counselor Robert Muller took over the
inquiry and now it's apparently part of
Muller's broader assessment of course no
evidence has come out publicly that mr.
Trump was secretly in contact or took
direction from the Russian government in
any way and there is no word of any
sourcing on the story we should note
that Rudy Giuliani has also issued a
statement saying quote the fact that it
goes back a year and a half and nothing
came of it that showed a breach of
national security means they found
nothing and Giuliani said that a short
time ago regarding the story
we'll get breaking news as it comes in
more on this from the New York Times
Tucker
trace Gallagher thanks for that so if
you're keeping track at home and get a
pen and paper because this is worth
remembering this is why you should never
criticize the FBI you think it's your
birthright isn't
American you can do it wouldn't try it
though they might open an investigation
into you without your knowledge into
something appalling maybe it's beating
your wife maybe it's dealing fentanyl to
kids
maybe it's betraying your country in
some alliance with Vladimir Putin you
don't need to have done it but once they
investigate you they can always leak I
don't know two years later that they
were investigating you for this crime
that you didn't commit or at least they
found no evidence that you committed at
least she's never charged you for it
which say our system is closed or open
it doesn't matter because you're
instantly discredited don't criticize
the FBI very unwise